[Music]
joining me today is the author of the
art of the argument western
civilization's last stand and the host
of free domain radio
stephon molyneux welcome to the reuben
report thank you
great pleasure to be here it's been a
while it has been a while i i've been on
your show a couple times
uh before we get into anything of real
substance though i do feel we have to
address the amount of gray that we both
have
in our beards because it what what's
with the chin area though
i don't know i mean first time i had a
beard and it went gray i've been outside
in canada in the winter
and i was like oh it's just a little bit
of you know a little snow a little ice
or something like that it's like doesn't
brush away
because it's father time doing his work
i have never had a beard in my life this
is my first beard ever so i didn't even
know
that gray was there now i feel old and
tired
and here's the thing too once you have
the beard in public view
you can't darken it no you can't because
it's too late like soon as you like
even if you get a bit of stubble because
you know there's people who obsess about
everyone's looks on the internet get a
little bit of stubble
you can't yeah you can't shoot polish it
up you can't do that you know you just
you got to let it go what number are you
buzzing with uh i'm sort of like a
number two kind of thing
i'm like eight oh okay we'll see
see i went into the controversial stuff
well now here's the thing because
you're okay because you have fairly
lengthy hair yeah but i
cannot be the guy with a beard much
longer than
his hair that's a hole like montana
living in the
caves kind of look that has you like
everyone thinks that you're cooking
beans on a fire in an old shoe waiting
for the end of civilization
there's got to be a youtube series about
that i'm sure but yeah so i've got to
keep it fairly trim
no matter which way yeah all right well
we have a lot to get to and i really
want to talk about the book but i
thought the
best way to sort of start this is that i
know i'm going to get a certain amount
of hate just for sitting across from you
and as i said i've been on your show a
couple times before and we've had
nothing but pleasant conversations
have talked about liberalism and logic
and reason and all that stuff
but i think you're you're somewhat aware
of that type of thing that for some
people you are
negative opinions about a a free thinker
on the internet i think actually
pre-internet it was socrates and then
you know copernicus not to put myself in
such lofty categories but
there certainly is when you are an
original thinker and when you really try
and
particularly when you scrub things down
to the bare minimum like
randy dickhardt said like what if i know
nothing whatsoever what if i just wipe
everything out and try and build a
cohesion
uh and rational framework of thinking
and
of understanding the world and of
understanding ethics what if i just
pretend i know nothing which is a
socratic commandment you know nothing
what are you gonna build from scratch
and i think that's the modern world
is when people said we don't know
anything we don't know whether the sun
or the the earth is the center of the
solar system we don't know anything
let's just pretend we know nothing we
don't even know if the king is put there
by god we don't know if the aristocracy
is put there by god we don't know if the
priests are right about everything what
if we just wipe the slate clean and then
we build things up
and we get modern civilization i think
out of that but there are a lot of
entrenched interests
that profit from existing error and when
people come along with better arguments
uh well it can be a little kind of like
it can be a little controversial
toss in a certain dose of twitter and
then yeah you know you get
where we are now it's funny because i've
had a little bit of a change over the
last couple of months where i was kind
of
really just you know everybody talks
about well we've never been more divided
we're all angry at each other we all
hate each other
i think there's actual great opportunity
right now for people that are talking
about ideas and i include you in that
but what would you say is the thing that
people uh
find most controversial about you is
there one topic that you consistently
hit on
that you think people either give you
the most flack or you think is sort of
wading into the most dangerous territory
if i knew that dave i would hit on it
more well
i've got a couple i've got a couple
right here but i thought i'd throw that
to you i think
i would say
i would say that the concept so so
there's some abstract ones and there's
some personal ones yeah and people tend
to get most upset about the personal
ones because that's where people have
kind of like a stake
in in their life in their world so for
me for sure i think
people get most upset when i talk about
say for instance
you don't have to have abusive people in
your life you know whether they're
that's what the one i have that's number
two i have one above that but let's
let's
we can start with that sure so you know
when i was growing up
i don't know for some of your listeners
they may you know paleozoic maybe
but when i was growing up this was
everywhere
when i was a kid and this was part of
the feminist revolution right where they
said
if you are with an abusive man you
should get out
you should you know hit the road jack
don't look back deep in the rear view
nothing but dust right and that was
something that i grew up if you're being
abused if you're in an abusive
relationship
then you should not be in that
relationship now i actually think that's
a little too harsh i think you should
sit down and talk with people and try
and reason things out and so on but
that seems relatively uncontroversial
when you're talking about adults but i
think one of the things that people got
upset about is when i logically at least
to me
extended that to if you're an adult and
you had an abusive parent
do you actually need to continue to
spend time with that abusive parent and
the answer to me is well
no because if you marry someone that's a
chosen relationship right i mean but
your parent is someone
like i'm a parent right and i recognize
that my daughter did not choose me she's
like eating me
there's no there wasn't like some you
know this platonic idea that you're kind
of floating above the world you look
down and you [ __ ]
unless there's some cosmic game that you
don't know about no i don't really i
mean
so she didn't choose me so it's an
involuntary relationship
for for children and to me you have to
have the very highest standards
when you have the least voluntary
relationship and so
when i put that argument forward um
well some people seem to get quite upset
and
it has always been you know from a
logical standpoint it's completely
baffling from a sort of personal
standpoint
i can understand why so on the logical
front it makes sense because you would
just remove bad influences from your
life whether they're
part of your family or not your family
it's just that that
i think well i think talk to them first
yeah i mean you don't that's what you
don't understand
how far do you think you have to go
before you would cut out
something like a parent
i i know it's yeah no i mean i i have
this sort of rule
i don't tell people what to do in the
show because i mean not only would that
be
kind of megalomaniacal but also let's
say somebody just obeys you they haven't
learned anything right so
i wouldn't so to say to people what but
i would say that
it's hard to have a better relationship
in your life than your worst
relationship
and so if you have a very dysfunctional
relationship and there are certainly you
know people out there whose
parents were unfathomably evil towards
them you know like a
molestation rape violent abuse you know
massive neglect and so on right so
i think try and talk to people in your
life
but do not think that it's like physics
that you just have to have relationships
because i'm very big for free will very
big for choices
and i always have a kind of reflexive
pushback
against you have to you know well
it's your father's birthday you have to
call him it's like well he beat me up
every day if our child said do i
do why do i maybe i'll skip this well
because because people don't say well
you chose this man you have to stay
married to him even if he's drunkenly
beating you every night people said no i
mean and
and again that's a chosen relationship
so involuntary relationships
i think there's a higher standard so i
think it's important you sit down you
talk about
if you've had a difficult history with
your family or parents sit down and talk
about it with them and you know if they
want to go to therapy or if they want to
try and find ways to resolve it
so much the better what can be repaired
should be repaired but that's not up to
you in the end
in the end is part of the conflict there
that so many of us walk around not
really
dealing with issues in the first place
so i remember once years ago about 10
years ago
a good friend of mine was telling me
about his relationship with his dad
he said his dad was abusive and was
always drunk and that one night
he came home his dad came home drunk and
basically just beat the living hell out
of him and that he as a 12 year old
knew at that moment this guy is just you
know
a dirtbag and i'm gonna always treat him
as such
and in a bizarre way he had very clean
feelings about it because the the act of
being punched and beaten was so clean
yeah but i think a lot of people if you
don't get
hit there's all sorts of other abuse so
you walk around in this sort of half
truth phase you know i mean you can't
quite parse it out do you think that's
part of it that people don't
quite yeah people have good mental
adventure yeah you know that there's
very few people in the world that's like
well that person was evil
from dawn until desk they woke up they
were evil and there was never i mean
people always have good memories
even of bad people in their life and so
it definitely is complicated and if you
can use the good memories as a way of
hooking
the relationship to a better place
fantastic but
we were talking just a little bit before
about you know the sort of weinstein
scandal and all this kind of stuff and
just while we were talking that the
thought popped into my mind dave that
we look at hollywood and we say oh you
know these people
they seem to know or there's lots of
indications or lots of jokes or lots of
stuff where people said
oh we knew we knew and then people why
didn't they say something why didn't
they say something it's like well you
can
think that the only problem with that is
somewhere out in hollywood some are out
among the rich famous pretty people
who have massive talent more money and
it seems like decreasing
levels of ethics as every day goes
forward but what about people in your
own life do you know
for instance not you personally but do
your audience do you do you the audience
know
somebody who's mistreating a child do
you know a parent who is
and this can be neglect neglect is a
very very powerful form of abuse
that is very hard to um unpack in in
your mind
do you have suspicions you know do you
see parents you know screaming at their
children or spending their whole time on
the cell phone and not talking to them
and so on
is there something that you can do to
improve that to remind them and say you
know
your kids are only young once try and
engage them in a positive way
teach them how to be rational by being
rational to them and love them and be
positive to them
because it's not just out there in
hollywood where there's all this bad
stuff that people
aren't doing people most people if you
have any kind of extended social circle
extended family and so on most people
have something
in their life that they could stand up
for and say this needs to be better this
should be improved
yeah and i think that's one of the
fascinations that's going on with this
hollywood scandal is people are saying
they do say well what about all the
people who knew but didn't do anything
but i think most of us
and i care myself in this as well in
parts of my life i've looked in the
mirror and said
i know that something's not right and
i'm skating over it i'm kind of
you know sidestepping it i'm crossing my
fingers i'm
or maybe just withdrawing contact if
there's some difficult situation you see
between a parent and child or anyone
so i think we all have that
responsibility but i think it's kind of
erupting in our consciousness through
that very distant event that's easier to
talk about for a lot of people yeah what
do you make of
this whole situation i mean we're
watching it seems like the entire
industry is collapsing in front of us
i know you're not a major fan of what
hollywood has been putting out in the
type of moral preaching that these
people do and i i'm not either
i don't mind moral preaching from good
people well right yeah
these people do um so that i i would
assume at some level you're you're
enjoying watching it be exposed but we
briefly for a second before we started
taping we're talking about how
this now could bring its tentacles
everywhere where everyone is gonna look
back and go 20 years ago someone touched
my knee
me too you know like that and i don't
want to really focus on that part but
but we just don't we're sort of opening
a pandora's box here that yeah that is
kind of dangerous
but i think it's essential yeah i mean i
think this has to be done and this
absolutely i'm glad
to be clear i'm glad the monsters are
going down well but who knows who's who
knows who's a monster at the moment
right now it's dark
there are lots of eyes out there there
are tentacles flying around like i don't
know who's a good guy and who's i mean
okay clearly there's some people like
the weinsteins and so on it's like
you know that's some pretty nasty stuff
and i know he's got a bunch of
investigations into rape
i think in new york there's no statute
of limitations so they can go after that
but right now
i think we're kind of in the midst of a
hysteria and and that
is fairly common when these kinds of new
things come out
so when i was a kid this was child abuse
sorry this was um a wife abuse wife
abuse was the big thing
that was going on you know this was not
talked about you kind of
i had um a feminist advocate aaron pitzy
on the show a couple of years ago and
she was saying that she ran one of the
first shelters
for uh women who were being abused and a
lot of times the priests would come down
and say
sorry love you got to go back you made a
vow and and all of this
this was when i was a kid this was the
big thing that was coming out and then
it was child abuse that came out a
little bit later
now this kind of sexual harassment stuff
is um
something that is coming out and
because it's kind of a hysteria it means
you know there are some bad people who
are being exposed
there are people who are kind of on the
line who are going to take some real
hits to their
reputations and of course inevitably
there are going to be some good people
who are taken down
unjustly and the you know what we need
to do is have a conversation about all
of this
as a whole you know where there is this
power disparity whether it's this sexual
exploitation
and i i do believe and i made this case
before that that
there is a very very dark heart
somewhere in in hollywood you know the
stuff that corey feldman has talked
about the stuff that
elijah wood talked about the the
pedophilia and and all of this
there is some very very dark stuff in
there and the what do you think the
genesis of that is do you think it's
just
power and money and then
crazy morals lack of morals i mean what
is it about hollywood
although this could be happening in any
industry right now and we just so happen
to know that we've
you know we're hearing about it in in
the sports world um
we've heard about it in academia i just
did a show recently on how prevalent
this kind of abuse can be in government
schools
it is i think it's just something that
needs to come out
where it comes from in particular
you know power corrupts and when you
have a lot of power when you have
huge numbers of people who want the
opportunities that you
offer them it's really
tempting and i think easy to use that
power i mean
as a public figure i'm sure you're aware
of the effect that you have on people
i'm aware of the effect that i have on
people and
it is very very important to be aware of
our everybody's fundamental capacity
to be corrupted by power and if you have
influence in the world you need to be
very very careful about how
you wield it but um there is a kind of
a gross sort of sensuality in certain
areas of hollywood
that um does not appear to have any
particular moral restraint
and you know i'm not religious myself
but
it is a godless world in
in hollywood and i don't know that they
have
the kind of abstract ethics that would
cause that restraint or that that
cognizance you know the one great thing
about christianity is how it talks about
the devil and temptations and fallen
humanity that puts you on guard against
your worser self
and if you're not on god against your
worser self and you have that kind of
power i think it's
a real slippery slope it's interesting
you just ended that with
that about atheism and christianity
because i've noticed lately and i'm
around obviously a lot of atheists
and i've talked to a lot of atheists and
believers and half believers and
non-believers and
whatever it is um but i do sense a
little bit
in the atheist community that there's
because secularism has gone so awry
suddenly or whatever not secularism as
much as just our systems seem to be
struggling right now
that i do sense that people have a
little more respect for certain pieces
of religion
a little bit does does that make sense i
would certainly be the poster boy for
that
for what it's worth i was very harsh on
christianity earlier in my career
and uh i have um apologized for that and
i have withdrawn
from that position because
the one thing that atheists i mean
intellectually that the position of
atheism is
very hard to assail it because you have
to go with faith and if you have an
empirical rational view of the universe
faith doesn't cut it faith is you know
i'm right it's just closing your eyes
and saying that you're seeing something
different is not the same as
being scientific so intellectually
atheism is a very very easy position but
the great challenge i think
that has happened you know seeing how
the rise of atheism is for
is causing also a rise in state power it
is causing a decay in borders and
boundaries in nation-states it is
causing a moral collapse
across society it is causing a blurring
of rational biological categories and
empirical methodologies so i think that
the big
concern i have is something like this
that
the world is a difficult and dangerous
place and we need i mean the world
within
our own hearts and the world that is out
there
we need ways to guide ourselves we need
ethics we need morality
now atheists looked at the religion
looked at religion and said
not true and again metaphysically
epistemologically
it's really hard to sustain the argument
for religion but
why did people believe in god did they
believe in god because they genuinely
believed
that loaves could be turned into fishes
and water could be turned into wine and
people could walk on water i would say
no i mean people didn't believe
that that was a way that they expressed
why they found it so important that it's
miraculous
but i think that they believed in
religion because it gave a structure of
self-restraint
that is essential for civilization and
we can talk about this with the book
that you need to
restrain your own capacity and for
violence and dominance and aggression
and bullying in order to have
rational discussions so people took
shelter into church
and the atheist came along and they said
that church
is terrible that church is not a valid
structure and they ripped
the roof off the church but it's hailing
and there's lightning
and people are then exposed to the
elements above
now okay rip the roof off the church but
you better build another structure for
people to get to
right so that's the missing piece that's
the missing piece and this is why the
one of the first things i did as a
public intellectual was work on a
rational system of ethics because we
need to have a reason to have
self-restraint if we don't have a reason
to have self-restraint
you know our like our inner apes come
out and it just becomes about power and
control
it's interesting because i had a really
great discussion on this with
michael shermer and with dennis prager
and michael is an atheist and a skeptic
and he
and basically dennis said that on the
micro level
he's like yeah you can be moral i have
no doubt that you're
looking at him in the face i have no
doubt that you're moral and all of those
things but on the
macro level for society and that's
really what you're talking about that
there isn't enough of a structure
otherwise
i think there's an interesting argument
there for sure well to me
atheist ethics is like it's like diets
for thin people
i mean if you're already thin well i
guess they would say it's enlightenment
values
well okay but they can say enlightenment
values but the reason we need ethics are
for people who really want to do evil
you don't i mean you're not i'm a nice
guy we're not sitting there going okay
there's a homeless guy there's a cinder
block
i could go drop the cinder block that we
don't have those impulses so for me
i don't have to fight this demonic lust
for
you know what but there are people out
there who really want that
and the fear of the devil and the fear
of hell and the fear of eternal
damnation kept those people in check it
was like a little prison that they could
walk around inside of they could rattle
the cages and so on but it
it kept them restrained right it's sort
of a depressing view of what humanity is
in a way it's like that some people
could escape it
yeah some people just need it it is sort
of and i guess that you could eventually
get out of it would
be the hope if that's what it is right
well the the data seems to be pretty
clear that if you're
raised peacefully as a child raised
reasonably as a child not hit
not screamed at not yelled not neglected
then you're going to grow up to be a
good person with empathy and so on but
you know like there's a couple of
percentage points out there
people who are genuine sociopaths and
psychopaths no conscience no remorse
will depower stuff what is going to
restrain them well
in the past there was the devil there
was hell there was
and there was condemnation and ostracism
by the community based on
universally held moral values the
atheist came along and
okay undoing god is one thing undoing
ethics
is quite another and if atheists say
well you know but we're
good it's like not all atheists not all
atheists are good and
when people give up on god and then they
give up on morality
as a result uh i think what we end up
missing is not god but morality and and
if we don't have that
need for self-restraint if we don't have
an understanding of the darker side of
human nature which we all carry
which we're all susceptible to the
atheists have a very optimistic view
that if you remove superstition from
people's lives
paradise and i don't see that
particularly playing out
right i guess this is where jordan
peterson who you've had on your show
several times and i've had on a bunch of
times would talk about these archetypes
that we just
need them yeah uh but it's so
interesting because you yourself are an
atheist and in a way anyone listening to
that
five minutes that we just did would go
this guy doesn't sound like much of an
atheist but i get you're making the
separation between your own intellect
and society i think it's a it's a really
rich spot
well i mean i this is just a question
which
you know people who are watching and
listening to this dave can
just go to the worst person they know
and try and merely reason them into
being
a good person no it is a it is a tough
road to hoe like i do a call-in show
every week hours and hours of talking
with people about
philosophy and virtue and how to improve
their lives and so on
and it's hard you know people go and and
try and talk other people into being
good and it's really really tough
on the other hand if you
are religious and it's you know hellfire
damnation
that's going to get people's attention
now you have in a sense you have heaven
to offer them and you have hell to
punish them with
now for us as a society you don't i
don't think you actually need
heaven and hell but you need rewards and
punishments
and jail is not enough
so the rewards and punishment that
normally occur within society
are acceptance and ostracism you know
there have been studies that that show
that if you are ostracized by a
community
it evokes the same mental and emotional
and physical states
as direct physical torture and and for
obvious biological reasons we needed
the cooperation of the tribe to
reproduce to survive to flourish
but we don't have the because we've got
this big giant redistributionist welfare
state we don't have the capacity to
ostracize anyone anymore people
you know that there used to be this very
tight control over teenage sexuality in
the past
and and there was chaperones and and you
know the the shotgun weddings and so on
right
right maybe a little too far in some
ways but
why did people care so much about
youthful sexuality why was there no sex
before marriage and so on
because if your daughter got pregnant
and there was no one around to be her
husband and take care of her you as the
parents would have to pay
to raise that child she'd move in with
you and then your whole retirement plans
would get scotched and there wouldn't be
any
playing bacharach on the southern
riviera of france or something and so
you had a direct impulse but now there's
this big welfare state
yeah you know it's not that great but it
doesn't directly impact me so we've lost
the capacity to ostracize people
and if you don't have hell and you don't
have ostracism
what the hell causes people to restrain
their bad behavior i don't
have an answer maybe there is one you
know the audience want to let us know
i'd love to hear it but i haven't seen
one yet well it's interesting because
also the welfare state in many ways
uh it benefits you to have more children
which is which is a whole other thing
but let's
let's circle back a little bit just to
the family no no i'm drawing you into
the welfare state
but just to sort of end the family thing
yeah um
because we did a very circuitous route
to the to the end of it
um so i think partly what people would
say and this is i was trying to find
okay
what are people criticizing stefan on
they say well what he's basically then
offering a cult that if you were to
disband
this thing about the family uh even if i
think
they you had legitimate reasons that the
alternative is it's sort of like come to
me
and join my cult i don't hear you saying
that i'm just joined by celts
yeah no no but you understand what i'm
saying yeah yeah but that's
that is sort of like well if you if
you're go if ultimately the family is
crumbling then then what's going to be
on the other side of it
i think well i don't think i would say
that the family is crumbling
at all my concern is the next generation
and if you had an abusive parent and
then you yourself become a parent and
you haven't resolved things with your
abusive parent and the abuse is most
likely going to be
to some degree at least transmitted down
the chain so my concern is the next
generation that you need to have a
positive peaceful and
rational environment to raise your
children in
and so that's my particular concern you
know regarding the cult thing i mean
okay so are people saying that the
family you can't leave
you know that's a little called that
seems like okay you can't leave it's
like a roach motel you check in
biologically through no choice of your
own but you can't ever get out
no matter how you treat it but let me
ask you
what do you think would be behavior on
the part of a parent
that may potentially justify an adult
breaking relations with them
well if it was an endlessly violent you
know physically violent or emotionally
violent
abusive relationship i i agree with you
once you're an adult
you have every right to manage your
relationships as you see fit
and if your parents either one of them
or your uncle or your brother or
whatever it was was abusive to you your
whole life if you
don't feel if you yeah it would be nice
if you can sit down hopefully and try to
talk some of this out which is what you
said earlier
but whether you do that or not if you
it's your choice i do believe in the
individual so i wouldn't
i don't operate on guilt so i wouldn't
try to guilt someone into not doing it
and i say that as someone that believes
that the bonds of family are incredibly
powerful perhaps the most powerful force
outside of us
so the other thing too
is that to take a somewhat
silly but i think important analogy
the post office not very efficient you
know
the department of motor vehicles you
know there's that sloth scene
in in zootopia you know just like it's
not an accident
that's a government place of employment
right and the reason why
these you know government schools and
the in the irs and like these big giant
government institutions the government
itself not particularly responsive
because you have no choice
now if you were to privatize the post
office this sounds like a political
argument but it's not
if you were to privatize the post office
then
we would assume that much like fedex and
and
other places that the service would
improve because now you have a choice
so the funny thing is that some people
have said that i am somehow doing
something negative to families
but the introduction of choice is what
raises quality
and so if parents out there
just assume that their children
will always have to spend time with them
we'll always be there for them we'll
show up for birthdays we'll be around
when they
when they get older no matter how badly
they treat them that's kind of like the
post office
there's no volunteers right there's no
incentive in a weird way whereas if you
introduce the idea
of voluntary relationships within the
family my goal is not to make the family
worse
it's like saying well you're going to
destroy the post office by privatizing
it's like no no we're going to get
better
by introducing the value of choice into
the post office and
what i want is you know like these these
old soviet factories you know like under
stalin you know
the old saying you know that they
pretend to pay us and we pretend to work
and they just
you know put out these in different
goods because there was no voluntarism
there was no
positive or negative consequences so
they didn't care but if parents
out there and i'm very happy that this
idea is out there of the voluntary
family because what it does
and i'm aware of it myself my daughter
when she grows up you don't have to
spend
any time with me so i better make her
childhood so great that she wants to
and so the privatization of the family
which is the removal
of well it's just like physics you have
to spend time with your family no matter
what
means that parents as a service provider
actually are operating more in the free
market actually operating more in the
realm of voluntarism and to me
everything we can move from absolutes
to voluntarism is how relationships get
improved so i do want
parents to sit there and say i kind of
want to yell at my kids but
i know they don't have to see me when
they get older so i'm going again how do
we restrain ourselves through negative
consequences and
if you can imagine like it's way back in
the day like up until the 60s in
canada where i live to get divorced you
need an act of parliament
now i was always told that easy divorces
improve the quality of marriage because
parents oh sorry because
because husbands in general say well my
wife could leave me so i oh
better be better right whereas if you if
you have to stay married
the quality of how you treat your spouse
goes down and so
in a sense by privatizing marriage by
allowing for no fault divorce by
allowing for reason i think it's gone
too far but
nonetheless by privatizing marriage by
making it more voluntary and making it
something you could stay in or get out
of
the quality of marriages i think in
general has improved if you privatize
the post office it'll improve if you
privatize the family of origin
i think it improves the goal is not to
make things worse the goal is to make
things better now
that can be tough for some people you
know if you try and privatize
the post office people need to go inside
right here this is the worst thing ever
catastrophe disaster right i mean
and i hate the guy who's saying
privatize the post office but
um the family needs to improve for
society to
improve and the only way i know how to
improve things is to privatize them okay
so we've talked about the family and
that's one of the things people find
controversial about you i think really
though the one that you didn't mention
is the race and iq stuff this is
something you you
dive into a lot and i think people think
that there is somehow a racist
element to it so i don't want to put any
words in your mouth so do you want to
make your basic argument around race and
iq
can you can you sort of can you sort it
no no no listen i'll be very clear about
this because
yeah it's like saying do you want to
make
your argument that the sun is the center
of the solar system it's like well it's
not a personal thing like
this is not an idea i have come up okay
so it's not your idea it's not like
my formulation like i've got some
beautiful mind set of like uh
charts and lines in my basement is like
it's all about the price
of magnesium man you know i mean so i'm
glad you countered with that because in
a way my question accidentally was
almost a set up so
yeah so i'll take that
i'm going to give a very very brief
history of of
what it is and for those who don't know
where the science is and i'm not a
scientist so you know people verify
all of this i've got a whole list of
interviews with subject matter experts
on on the show about this topic so
listen to the experts this is my
amateur summation just for those who
want to know so
the the us army for over 100 years has
been giving
more or less iq tests to people to
figure out whether they're sort of
officer material or
you know grunt material so to speak and
what they noticed was
between blacks and whites and this
becomes this bichromatic nonsense
because
the the question of ethnicity and iq is
a whole layer cake
you know just very briefly that the very
top the ashkenazi jews it's
the jews that are the uh the wandering
jews so to speak the ashkenazi jews
you're sitting across from an astronomy
too can you feel the iq just i actually
am trying to hoover up some
some language skills from you uh i'll do
it later with a straw but
i've been dumbing it down for you so i
know and i appreciate that you know you
know
as a caucasian i really need to go slow
yeah lots of subtitles hand puppets
help as well so yeah ashkenazi jews as
you know and
the science is like 115 iq on average
but lower on spatial reasoning and
higher like
even higher than 115 iq on verbal stuff
right i mean
verbal acuity among ashkenazi jews is
through the roof
and the highest recorded that there is
some of how this fits with our general
experience i mean
what we're talking about everybody kind
of knows deep down it's just that we
don't have the scientific language or
the mathematical language to describe it
when that's what we're trying to do so
you know there's not a lot of famous
jewish architects or engineers because
jews test an average
around the hundreds in in spatial
reasoning
but crazy high on verbal acuity verbal
reasoning so
of course you would expect among
novelists among playwrights among
lawyers where high verbal iq is very
important
you're going to find a lot of ashkenazi
jews and lo and behold
you do so what that means is that let's
say ashkenazi jews at 120 125 verbal iq
and there's a certain proportion of them
in the language field but it's not
anything to do with
judaism it's to do with iq and so what
that means is that
if you look at any group of people
wherein they're in that iq
they're going to be equally represented
or proportioned
and then under that you have i don't
know the word oriental has kind of come
out of favor which is kind of
annoying in a way because how do you
differentiate people from india people
from south
east asians whatever the chinese
japanese and so on uh
10300 405 iq in general
very high on uh spatial reasoning which
is why you know
software engineers uh other kinds of
engineers you see that you know like
google has this like it's like 40
or something like that of their
engineers or not much more because after
this diversity thing goes through
they're going to just have to pick
everybody by color and all that
but but this is the thing right so if
you're looking at east asians with very
high spatial iq
they're going to be quote
over-represented in those engineering
fields and so on but
not because everyone who's got that iq
is up there there just happened to be
more of those right
you've got uh your run of the mill
vanilla caucasians coming in
at a hundred that then a hundred is just
i don't know it's just that the baseline
they recalibrate it from time to time
and so on
and then uh below i i did some of this i
think
what comes the cells or or uh hispanics
sometimes called oh that's very
loosey-goosey
term and uh that's sort of 8590
and so on and then you've got uh blacks
uh in in
north america particularly uh african
americans coming in at
85 and there's been some upward drift a
little bit uh and then uh below that you
start to get uh
sub-saharan blacks 70 there are pygmies
at uh
in the high 50s low 60s there are um
the uh indigenous people of australia i
think in the low 60s and some of these
numbers again i don't have them all
tattooed on my you know wrist or
anything but so there is this
range it is unbelievably heartbreaking
i mean just just i'm straight up about
all of this like this is one of the
most difficult facts
i've ever had to absorb in my life i
mean i've gone through a bunch of
iterations
as a thinker um you know i was a
christian and and a socialist and and
all i mean i've gone through i'm gonna
go through a whole journey
but i found almost nothing harder to
absorb
than this question of differences in iq
between
groups and this goes back many many
decades uh this was talked about by
hernstein in murray of course in the
bell curve
in 94 and nobody's been able to overturn
that and their basic argument
is to say look blacks
make less money than ashkenazi jews
but if you normalize by iq they don't
and this is
again it's heartbreaking stuff and it is
so difficult
to absorb this into your daily thinking
because i was like
well i just want to pause you for a
second because it's interesting you're
describing it as heartbreaking and
struggle because that's what i was going
to ask you is that
because you do talk about this stuff um
i was going to ask you are you troubled
by it because i don't know that i've
gotten that exactly through your videos
but i obviously haven't seen everything
you've done on this
so hearing you frame it in that way is
actually different than the
a bit of the impression i had of you on
this oh
do you know how much i would give
dave to to know that it was just racism
because that's a solvable problem and
and people have been working on trying
to solve the problem of racism
but for hundreds of years i mean
it is i mean i wouldn't say i give my
left arm because i'm left-handed but i
would give a lot
to i would give so much for it to just
be racism
so if you look at criminality
right i mean as you know uh black males
are
you know young black males three to four
percent of the american population
responsible for more than fifty percent
of the homicides you look at what goes
on to the south side chicago
it's horrible and yet in general
it is not if you normalize by iq
everybody who has an iq of 85 has
similar levels of criminality
whites in america have a certain
particular level of homicide that's
pretty low
and whites around the whole world have
the same level of homicide
whites in england whites in belgium
whites in america all have the same
level
of homicide and
the question of course is environment
versus
genetics i would love to have a clear
answer to that
um science is making its way forward but
it's such a volatile topic that a lot of
scientists
you know like would rather do anything
than than delve into this particular
topic but uh
it is oh it's extraordinarily
heartbreaking and
it means to me that no amount of
screams of racism can be guaranteed to
solve the problem and i think isn't that
what we've seen that the consciousness
about
race and racism has gone up so
enormously and and good you know like
this there was definite
racism in the world but without this
central
fact and it is a fact at the moment even
if we say it's 100 environmental it's
still a fact at the moment
you know even if we say well but is
there evidence that it's genetic
this is i'm not a geneticist genetic in
what regard i mean if we took
the brain of a 25 year old black man in
the brain of a 25 year old white man
what is it that they're doing that
different sizes
yeah yeah and again this is dependent on
every ethnicity the higher iq in general
there's lots of exceptions and so on
there are different sizes there as
evidence that um
if you take a um
a white kid from a middle-class
household for whatever reason ends up
being raised by a black family the white
kid's gonna end up about 100 iq if you
take the average black kid have them
raised by an upper class middleweight
family or a jewish family and so on
they're going to end up
at about 85. so it does not appear to be
strongly environmental i don't believe
that there's no environmental causes you
know i've done
lots of videos where i strongly urge the
black community to
to breastfeed longer to to not hit their
children to do things that
will give their kids the best shot at
having higher iqs because that's going
to make a huge amount of difference in
american society and this is something
that
people need to talk about more is
equality and black parenting the quality
of black parenting around the world but
you know where
in america the most could possibly be
done is is still quite
low they hit their kids the most uh and
uh
if that can be improved i mean who knows
what could change how far do you go down
the rabbit hole of where all that starts
you know what i mean that that the most
black people in america their ancestors
were brought here as slaves
that they didn't have equality for many
hundreds of years all of this
and then end up in poorer neighborhoods
then they get stuck on the welfare
system and
of course we're painting with sort of
broad brushes here of course but that is
the environmental factor right
yes and i you know there's nobody who
says no no sane person who says
any human characteristic is 100 genetic
um but again and i would love to i mean
i'm
very keen on improving um particularly
childhoods that's where i think the big
thing is
but you know a couple hundred years ago
in europe
uh people were like a foot shorter than
they are now and that
was not genetics that was environment
you know not enough vitamin d not enough
nutrition as a whole and back breaking
labor and starting in childhood and so
on
and so even if we were to say it's 100
environmental
these are the issues that we have right
now so let's say that that
i could have been seven feet tall but i
didn't get enough food as a kid
okay so that was environmental but i'm
still not seven feet tall at the moment
maybe my kids it could be different and
so on but uh
nobody knows how to improve it at the
moment that's the challenge you know you
get this head start program
what do they pour 100 billion dollars
into trying to close the black white
achievement gap
and with no effect a few little bits at
the beginning and then
it all generally tends to fade away so
it is something that
it it's a very difficult unpleasant
challenging phenomenon when we have
different iqs and we haven't even talked
about male female which again is a whole
other
challenge to to sort of absorb and
understand but
you know and it's funny because the left
is always complaining about i'm neither
left nor right but the left is always
saying
anti-science people are anti-science and
so on this is science iq
is a very very good measure it's one of
the few metrics in the social sciences
that
is you know measurable empirical it's
predictable right i mean if there was
some if people's iq was wildly different
from where they ended up in life
then it would be less valid but it's
very close it's a very close correlation
to where people end up and nobody knows
how to change
disparate ikeas yeah well one of the
things that you do in your videos that i
really like is you often
offer your audience a chance to educate
you and you say
send me links send me you know some
information that might change my opinion
on this
so i think what we'll do for this
episode is we're going to find a couple
articles about this we'll
find something on the brain size we'll
find something on ashkenazi jews and
all of this stuff and we'll put it down
below and hopefully we can get some of
the conversation going on this
uh because i think it's just one of
those things that
it wades everyone into dangerous
territory and especially these days when
when everyone's accused of racism
endlessly
even if you're trying to find answers to
hard questions and i think we actually
i think both of us know we can actually
learn a little something from our
audience so
when i watch you do these videos and i
just watched your syria video that you
did the other day
and you said to people something to the
effect of don't just give me your crazy
theory
like it's not a theory i want a link i
want i want a paper yeah
and some science so and i've i've had
you know i've had the subject matter
experts on my show the geneticists
and and the social scientists i've had
people who believe that it's almost
exclusively environmental on to make the
case i've had people who believe that
there's some genetic
strong genetic elements and so on so i
am
gosh i mean it would be you know if i
could there were very few theories
that would be absolutely fantastic for
me to find disproven you know because
i've got a lot invested in my belief
system as everyone does but
boy if somebody could come along with a
way to say it it can be solved through
this or this is the cause or whatever it
is right i mean that would be fantastic
but right now the problem of course is
and people say to me a lot and and this
came up in a conversation i think
between
sam harrison and charles murray charles
murray was on his show talking about
this
well why do you even want to bring this
up you know isn't this going to fuel
racists and isn't this it's like well
first of all
it's an important fact and and we are
tortured as a society
by group differences i mean i think i
think that's fairly i mean don't you
we endlessly talk about groups well they
are real and they're tragic
you know when you look at the the
average net income of ashkenazi jews and
you compare it to to blacks
it's worlds apart and and it's
horrible because if it is just attitude
if it is just
racism that's horrible and needs to be
resolved
on the other hand if it is to some
degree genetic or for whatever reason
it is what it is like let's say that
there's a group of irish people didn't
get enough to eat and they've ended up
being four and a half
feet tall well they're not going to make
it in the nba now we can say well maybe
they're kids and so on but saying the
nba is prejudiced against
these short irish people for no reason
whatsoever would be crazy
i always thought the nba was prejudiced
against ashkenazi jews but
here we are although you know the
history of jews and basketball right
i know you guys got it going right yeah
what are you going to do
so i mean that's what i'd rather be
doing for after the show
yeah um but but the other concern as
well and maybe this comes out of being a
parent and so on
and i did weigh you know i read the
bell curve way back in the day and i did
way before i mean i don't just
get up and do shows like hey man
inspiration striking
you know i mean i did sort of weigh the
pros and cons
the issue is that um if the
if the iq differences are significantly
genetic
it's a tragedy but it's no one's fault
i actually think that if you think let's
say that you think that that um
blacks are the exactly the same as
ashkenazi jews and the question is why
the blacks failing
relative to jews you could say
racism you could say there's something
dysfunctional in the black culture you
could say whatever right
it's rap music but all of those involve
negative judgments about groups
right so either you know jews and and
whites and
and east asians and hispanics are just
horribly racist
well that's a terrible negative judgment
to make about entire groups of society
or you say well there's something wrong
with the black community because you
know you've got these guys from from
um what was it i think it's in nigeria
or something the blacks come over from
nigeria they have a higher per capita
income than whites
in america so if it's just racism i mean
physically they're indistinguishable
from american blacks a lot of them speak
fluent english so if it's just or you
know like
the great dr tom soul who recently
retired you know wonderful guy and
i'm interviewing him in january i think
oh you're gone yeah we we're we're going
up to stanford and doing it wow
did you like hire doc the bounty hunter
to get this guy because he was
we did a lot of leg work for the last
two three years
you might recognize me from the closet
earlier yeah i really like to interview
you that's why i pulled everything
from my own command good no i'd like to
see that yeah i'd like to see that so
i mean he did well and nobody's sitting
there saying you know
so i just if there if there is a genetic
element involved
or something which is kind of hardened
even through environment that's what we
have to work with
then saying either somehow there's
something wrong with the black community
or everyone else is completely racist
involves dumping massively negative
judgments on entire communities
which if there are genetics involved or
other environmental factors that we
we don't as yet know or can control for
it's incredibly bigoted either against
the black community or everyone else
for things that are beyond all of our
control and i
that to me is i don't want people
looking down at the black community i
don't want everyone saying
that we have this magic answer called
racism that explains everything because
it doesn't
it doesn't and you know it's
it's different in a way because why do
you think you're so passionate about
this topic particularly because i was
even thinking when i i listened to
uh charles marion sam's podcast and i
thought it was a great conversation and
obviously as they're doing it you can
feel they're wading into things that
it's uncomfortable to talk about as
we're doing right now
but i noticed that immediately after the
usual cast of characters and salon i
think and
all the usual nonsense websites again
just pouring on the accusations of
racism and now sam's a
white extremist or whatever just the
nonsense is
so i think a lot of people just view
this as just the opportunity cost on
this is just too high
to even wade into it but you obviously
don't
i mean this is going to sound
self-serving i'm aware of this ahead of
time but uh
i'm going to be i'm going to be straight
straight up with you man
i want to solve problems in society i
want to fix things in society and i
don't
for the life of me i can't understand
how we fix things by ignoring facts
i fundamentally i cannot understand how
we're going to ignore things how we're
going to solve anything
by ignoring facts maybe there is a fix
maybe there is something that can be
done
i'm sure there is something that can be
done but if we don't even acknowledge
the problem
how are we going to solve anything and
i really really i find that the plight
of and it's not just a black community
but the f the plight of communities
around the world and in the western
countries
is dire and we are currently tearing
ourselves apart as a society
looking for the scapegoats for these
group differences and
the science is very clear at the moment
about
what the s what the problem is we don't
know again all of the causes and so on
but i'm sure we could find it pretty
quickly
but if we we are going to self-destruct
as a society if we continue to have this
incredible witch hunt
for racism and sexism and all
like if we have we're just looking in
the wrong place and we're going to tear
ourselves apart
because this is not like the difference
between the world being flat and the
world being round it's not like the
difference is the sun or the earth the
center of the solar system
you can be a farmer either way you you
but but if this is like
our big thing and we are screaming and
turning over stones and screaming racism
and destroying people's lives and
and massive government programs designed
to to fix everything and
propagandizing children that their
entire history and tearing down statues
everyone's a racist
if if it's wrong we are destroying
ourselves
through ignorance and that for for the
society that we have and the information
technology that we have and the
communications ability we have
for us to to self-destruct
through ignorance of scientific facts is
unprecedented in human history
you know the roman empire didn't
collapse because they thought the world
was flat
you know but but if we look at what's
going on in europe and and population
displacements and movement and so on
if we don't understand the basic science
behind what is going on
it matters it really matters about where
society is going to go
because if we ignore facts you know it's
like you got some weird lump on your
body and i'm not going to see a doctor
i'm going to walk it off you know i'm
sure it's going to be fine you know i'll
switch to decaf or everything i'll never
switch to turmeric i think is the answer
to everybody yeah yeah
some oil yeah but if you ignore reality
i mean reality just wipes you out and so
i am very passionate about it because
you know i think too you know i mean i'm
a father i don't want my daughter
growing up with everyone screaming
racist at her and they're going to
unless we try and figure out what the
facts are
yeah it's just interesting i mean i can
i can feel the passion coming out of you
when you talk about it it's just
interesting because i see so many people
try to wade into this
and then eventually they just are like i
can't do it i don't want to deal with
the blowback
uh but you've you've put your position
out there and and i'm
happy to discuss this again you know in
a couple months well and
again people you know if you can prove
me wrong i am beyond thrilled i will
apologize to everyone although again
having had all the experts on i'm on a
firm ground again i'm no scientist but
i've had the scientists on
yeah well it's it's a good segue to your
book the art of the argument western
civilization's last stand
now i had douglas murray on are you
familiar with douglas oh yeah yeah so i
had douglas on about two months ago and
his book is called the strange death of
europe
um you're so you're both sort of talking
about the same thing but at first what
you're talking about here
is that we don't even know how to argue
properly we don't even know how to have
conversations properly it's it's a good
jump off of exactly what you just ended
very well negotiated very well navigated
how about that huh we almost know what
we're doing around here right um
what do we what do we do to strength i
mean the basic premise of this what do
we do to strengthen
our argument we're always going to have
disagreements
uh and the question is how we're going
to resolve them and
there's really only two ways we reason
or we use force the only two ways that
things get
get done things get dealt with we either
the two of us you know if we say we want
to go to a particular restaurant
you know i mean we have to submit to
where that restaurant is and go in that
direction you know i mean we have to
have some
way that we subjugate our will to power
and the traditional way
in the west post-socratic with
a few large breaks in between and we may
be in one of them right now i think we
are
has been okay if i make a better more
rational argument if my argument is
rational and sound and the premises and
blah blah and
and the empirical evidence supports me
you agree that we're both submitting to
this
third party called reality truth reason
evidence right
and that way you and i can meet in
reality and we can both subjugate our
will to power according to an objective
standard scientists do it mathematicians
do it engineers do it all the time
there's a third standard called
a third party called reality objectivity
scientific method whatever right
and we have lost that
third standard the third standard or the
objective standard
used to be religious texts you know for
a long time under catholicism it was
what the priest said what the pope said
that was infallible you know
martin luther comes along with the
printing press and it all collapses and
into the reformation and religious war
and eventually you get a separation of
church and state
but if we don't have that third party to
adjudicate our disputes we end up with
you and i battling each other like two
pieces of paper being pushed together
you know we can't
one of us is gonna have to buckle under
another one and that's where you get all
this bullying this escalation this
pulling fire alarms you know throwing
fake blood at people and and
hitting people with with bike locks and
so on you get that when people
aren't able to find a subjective third
party to subjugate
their will to power their will to
dominance for and
if we lose that we lose everything yeah
so it seems to me that right now we've
you know everyone knows we've cordoned
ourselves off these days and because of
social media you only follow news
sources that catered away on
so but if we can't agree on basic facts
which really is what you're talking
about
we can only do the dance of logic and
reason and really
arguing your point if we can agree on
some basic principles
we seem to be veering into territory
right now where we can't agree on that
how
is there you think there's a way to
correct that before we get to you know
it's the stuff yeah
or the argument i mean you know i had a
caller in
to my show recently is a a black guy
called into the show had a great
conversation and he was saying that
there's lots of people in his community
who genuinely believe that mike brown
was shot execution style
in the back by a racist cop and
he wasn't spoiler right he wasn't yet
it's very well
and so if there are groups who have
these beliefs
and there are other groups who have more
accurate or empirical beliefs
people have to submit their preferences
to objectivity that's
i mean i'm a universalist this is the
philosophy gig right you have to come up
with universals that people are willing
to submit
to because you know the old thing nature
to be controlled
must be obeyed you don't get and if you
just make up your own standards of
gravity you're not going to get very far
but we do have to passionately commit
ourselves to
submission because right now i don't
know if you've ever had this in your
life i've had people in my life where
i don't i didn't want to submit to them
because it felt like a personal loss
you know like a personal oh we've got
that ego you know i don't wanna
i'm gonna win and i don't know and and
when i sort of relax and say okay well i
have these positions but they're based
on reason and evidence
and i don't lose if somebody teaches me
something better i win right i mean
if you go in the wrong way and you stop
someone and say oh you got to go the
other way you don't say
you're contradicting me you bastard when
you say well good now i get to go
where i want to go but we have to have
those objective standards and back to
the where we started
dave we have atheists who are not i
think focusing as hard as they could
on bringing forward these objective
standards atheists
again should be all over the race in iq
stuff because that's science as far as
we know it at the moment
but they don't and i think social
conflicts escalate thereby
yeah so if we can't agree on the facts
but we can make what then isn't there
like this really crazy
that's it's almost as if society is
going to split in two in a weird way
two people or it'll split it'll split a
gazillion ways but i think
that's like sort of the death star at
the end of star wars just had a change
of direction you know that's where we go
right are you
are you a star wars guy we could do star
wars i bought the album
when i was a kid the original the
original
i have it in the in the green room there
i found the original lp
man on the streets of new york city i
bought it for three bucks
like 10 years ago wow the original 1977
that was my one and then the poster that
i have in there next to the the
makeup thing is the poster that came in
it which i didn't know i had until about
a year ago when i moved
fell out of the thing yeah i listened to
that and loved it because this is back
before
vcrs and all this kind of stuff and that
was the only way you could enjoy it was
to close your eyes and
imagine yeah oh about what i would have
given for a lightsaber
i just like i just i've got a lightsaber
too no but it's not one that can take
down a telephone pole so you know
i'm working on that all right wait wait
we could do star wars
the real rift here yes there's going to
be a rift of like a thousand different
cracks and we're all going to
go in different directions but that the
rift will be
the people that want to have an argument
whether they agree or not so let's
you know we could probably sit here for
the rest of the day and find 10 things
we disagree on but we'd
do it civilly and we'd you know if you
made a point i'd concede it and i think
you'd do the same thing and all that so
we'll have that set of people
but then we're going to have the larger
set of people that just can't agree
that can't agree on the facts so it's
like we'll have this good
faith group that's going to be doing
it's going to be a small group but uh
but intellectually powerful
and rigorous but then everyone else that
unfortunately just can't even get out of
that world so it's sort of like we have
to give these people
a bit of a lifeboat or something i think
that's sort of why we both do
well this is you know like this book i
mean i'm hugely influenced of course by
socrates and what does socrates do
he didn't take a phd sitting in ivory
tower and talk about the ethics of the
babylonians right i mean socrates went
down into the marketplace and talked to
people about what mattered to them as a
reason i do a call-in show for like
three or four hours
a week because i want to talk to people
and find out how philosophy can help
them and and what they're struggling
with and what
matters to them and right at the
beginning of the book by the way you
mentioned you know you're saying that
basically this isn't some academic paper
that's just like
some flimsy nonsense because we see this
now all the time yeah these academic
papers that get peer reviewed and
they're the most
peterson you just had on jordan peterson
he was saying that 80
of papers in social sciences never gets
cited once
not once they just the library has to
buy them they stick them in a shelf
somewhere and kind of makes me wish i
went into academia
no it doesn't i know i know it does but
no it doesn't do
that i know utility right that uh shadow
lands thing you ever see the movie
shadowland no
no it's a great bit it's a fantastic
movie but uh anthony hopkins uh playing
in academic is talking to some other one
and he says
don't you ever get this feeling of
ultimate futility almost like well of
course
yeah but no i i wanted to write a
colloquial
book on on well first of all you have to
tell people why it's important
because everyone has this negative view
of arguments like what do you think if
you think of some bickering couple
um like oh man i remember this popped
into my head
just now many years ago i worked
after high school i wanted to save money
to go to college and um
i worked gold panning prospecting like
all this really rough stuff
up north stuff and i remember staying in
a uh it's a bit of a rude story but i
remember staying in
a lodge and and hearing this horrible
old married
bickerton couple screaming at each other
and um
it got to the point where like the man
was like yeah well your sister
gives better blow jobs than you and i
was like oh
i'd rather be in the woods like i'll
take a bear over this kind of human
and we think of this like you know
there's bickerton stuff this maneuvering
you see this online all the time people
won't give up their positions they
they inflame they add homonym that all
this kind of stuff and so i wanted to
give people a more positive flavor of
arguments a more positive flavor of of
debate that it's a chance to be informed
it's a chance to learn it's a chance to
sharpen your skills
in verbal debate and that is
civilization civilization starts we put
down the club and we use our words
it's all we've got yeah i mean there's
no there's no plan c there's a club
there's your words and that's it there's
nothing else we've got no backup plan
there's no plan c
that's it that's all we have and when
you see aggression and coercion
escalating in society which we see
online bullying and aggression and all
that we see with the expanding
state trying to solve every conceivable
problem we have in the known universe uh
because the state is coercion it's an
agency of force and that's because
force rushes in where words fail to
tread and this is why okay i'll talk
about controversial issues because i
know that the alternative is
if i back off and you back off and other
people back off from controversial
issues
it's not like well everyone just said
okay well we're not going to deal with
them at all what happens is then people
who are sophists and and the violence
mongers they
come in instead and they start telling
everyone what to do at the point of a
gun and that's not good
yeah and that's really exactly why i
wanted to return the favor and have you
on my show and not just do your show
because
whether every argument you made here was
perfect and as you said you're not a
scientist and
and you're open to those challenges that
this is the only thing that's going to
get us out of this craziness so if i'm
afraid of taking some heat for having
you on
or if you're afraid of having some heat
for having peterson on or
whatever it is and it i don't even mean
you in this case
so specifically but any of these people
if we all get afraid of talking
to each other then it's really the jig
is up
the only thing i'm afraid of about
having jordan peterson on my show
is that i'm gonna look like an idiot
because the man is so supernaturally
intelligent
i'm basically just holding his train
daintily and i believe that the uh the
top comment on my interview with him
from last week was dave you're an idiot
so
you have to have you know some humility
around that you know
listen it was a pleasure talking to you
i hope we'll do this again because
there's obviously so much more that we
can
that we can get into all right for more
on stefan you can find him right here on
youtube it's youtube.com
free domain radio
you